basketball and that's exactly what they
need to do if Washington wants to stay
home and everybody else on top this is
the way you want to play and I fully
expect these two guys three with it
afters by to kick out DeMar DeRozan
drills at way in Toronto 244 combines
once the 225
DeRozan right to the rim and is one
battle skipping into the frontcourt
attacking cuts it away scooped up by
DeRozan tomorrow - hey
the shot clock with a rat is cooked
they get back in transition and DeRosa
knows what to do it
standing screener balance units for the
rapper's uh keep this clips war-whooping
now was late to the party
that would be a little more consistent
and steady offensively here believe they
involve JV here's the screen DeRozan
with his channel droves it getting that
momentum going they've had good moments
and I gotta get a little more consistent
DeRozan with Peralta he's got 22 now
jack on a 2-14 shoot
block it off the shots and change a
release point on the jump shot Rosen and
he's got 24 now we're ton
look at his little clip bang they're
really doing a good job cuz Gortat
sitting in the painted area is hurt
picked up in early April Wow finds
Turtles clock down to 7 shot clock at 6
DeRozan tots by DeMar DeRozan
[Applause]
in Tunis getting the
is right here
the high screen
[Music]